could you well no need to pay me i'll
just play you
right now okay john just let's go
because i wanted to play somebody a
little bit higher rated
[Music]
you got you got your wish if you know
all support is
optional you know if you feel like
supporting me i always appreciate it but
i'm happy to do what i the small things
that i can to help people out
okay so let's play a sicilian
and we are we have been playing the
night or
quite extensively recently which which
isn't always involved opening i know
there are beginners among you who are
probably rolling their eyes but i've
explained it quite extensively and i
think people can tackle it so bishop g5
has not been played against us
yet this is considered to be the most
dangerous line against the niner black
white deploys the bishop to the most
active square and generally
follows it up with f4 so first of all
bishop takes f6 is a positional thread
that ruins
that completely ruins black's pawn
structure so there are two main ways to
defend against that there's knight b to
d7
to reinforce the knight and there's e6
to bring the knight under control
from the queen uh my main move is knight
b7 this move has
bee has actually experienced a
resurgence in recent years
and f4 played anyway now we normally
bring our queen out
onto a good square it's important to
understand
that white has this ultimate idea of
going e5 and if white gets e5
black's entire position collapses so
queen c7 is
is a good move in general bringing the
queen to the semi-open file
and and coordinating the pieces a little
bit better queen b6 is also possible
there's a lot of possibilities here we
will play h6 at some point
and uh yeah you have to be comfortable
playing crammed positions if you're
playing the night or
but uh often times by move 15 the
position uncoils
you're you eventually get your pieces
onto better squares
okay i'll i'll explain that after the
game like the
opening technicalities i'll i'll tackle
and i'll just write some of them down
thank you the weko
so you want to know why not 6 e5
yeah okay so queen f3 now
we're going to play h6 to test where
this bishop wants to go
and if he plays bishop okay so here and
i want you guys to bear with me there's
a very interesting gambit
which is not that well known but it's
very dangerous
now here's here's the bottom line here's
the bottom line
this knight on d7 we really want it on
e5 really wanted on this beautiful
outpost
and what i'm about to do is actually
more typical than the night or than some
people might realize
i think by now this is probably a
typical gambit but when i first analyzed
this many years ago
this was not very well known i analyzed
it with some dutch friends
uh who are now all gm's and you know we
we concluded that g5 is very strong here
and i think it's it's withstood
the test of time so the bottom line is
we are uncoiling our position we're
getting the knights e5
and when we do that we're going to be
attacking the queen so you guys can see
like
we're basically going to play a lot of
moves here with tempo
and uh there's a very interesting move
that happens if he takes twice
before we go 95. i don't remember this
very well but
i'll try to reproduce it apparently it's
uncheckable course yeah
makes sense i am commentating todd still
today of course
how could i not um
that's why i'm up so early and that's
why i forced myself to
stream because i didn't want to go back
to sleep and
god forbid oversleep
but all the caffeine in this tea is
keeping me
keeping me pretty uh pepped up
it's uh ceylon
tips on how to sleep less you know
try to love what you do and you know put
it out of your mind and
you know reduce self-pity to a minimum
okay bishop g3 so that is a mistake
that is a mistake because we look at
this knight we say ah
this is a possibility you guys a lot of
you suggested this
to make this an even stronger
possibility hello komodo thank you
as i said it's sale on to you guys how
can we make the
possibility of e5 even stronger okay
folks i
i don't mean to be salty here but i do
ask that we focus you know in general
it's okay to ask questions but
we focus mostly on the games i really
really every game i try to craft in a
certain way
and the purpose of it will be lost if
people don't like concentrate and
and watch the progression and now we go
e5 we pin
we fork bishop and knight
okay
so we play e5 and uh we are in good
shape
this game goes over my head that's okay
we will make sure that you understand
everything
but do you understand the fork
at least tell me this my bzz
do you sort of fully understand the fact
that we're winning a piece here
okay so i'll show you guys the theory
yes
key blundered yes yes yes and i'll show
you guys the theory
yeah yeah of course i'll explain
everything
no so so i'll show you guys there's a
lot of theory here
well that's the problem right you
understand my explanations but then you
try to play on that level on your own
and you find that everything falls apart
i feel much the same way
when i see mass when i see magnus
carlsen at work although in the titled
arena i
inherited some of that carlson magic for
an hour
that's where prop okay so knight b5 he's
trying to find the best version of
giving up the piece
obviously we have to take well we should
take the knight and now we should decide
where we put our queen so
there's a couple of tempting moves but
none of them are good
so the first tempting move is queen a5
this might
be a false uh belief that we're
accompanied to the false belief that
we're winning the bishop but remember
that your opponent can
simultaneously move away a piece and
defend against the check
queen a5 there's bishop d2 queen a5
check there's bishop d2 otherwise we
would take a second
piece the other tempting move is queen
takes you too but you guys
always have to this has to get the alarm
bells ringing in your head
queen takes c2 that queen is all alone
in the middle of white's position and it
allows rook c1
and when the queen moves let's say to b2
this gives white the possibility of
delivering a fork on c7
that is still good for black at the end
of that line as i will show you guys
but there's absolutely no need for any
of it
we should instead try to put the queen
on a square where it's semi-unassailable
and perhaps it's also doing something
we have a lot of conditions here to
fulfill but there is a square that
fulfills all of these conditions
and then that square is c6 the queen is
pressuring you for it is maintaining its
pressure on c2
it is maintaining its pressure on the
knight it's doing all these things and
it's
you know standing sentinel over c7
black is up a piece simply
well there wasn't much to calculating
queen c2 rook c1 is pretty pretty
straightforward
uh eat popcorn always as i explained
queen a5 check he can go bishop d2
and defend against the check bringing
his bishop back from the attack
okay we have another donation five bucks
from max evans 23 thank you sir
loved your commentary yesterday hope you
had fun absolutely i did
okay so bishop e3 he drops the bishop
back
we can consider taking the pawn here um
i'm not usually a big fan of over over
being overly greedy
when we are already up a piece so i
would emphasize instead of completing
our developments
which we could do with one move but
on the other hand let me think for a
second
on the other hand there don't seem to be
too many repercussions from taking
either so
yeah yeah let's go bishop p7 let's play
it simple let's play it safe
nothing wrong with being cautious and
then we
uh how do we deal with this bishop how
do we deal with this bishop folks
the king is going to stay in the center
for now it doesn't need to castle and
doesn't owe any anybody anything
well d5 was bad for a tactical reason
and i will that's a very instructive
thing actually
one second writing this down
okay
all right so let's see what kai jon
comes up with here i mean
yeah so you guys are suggesting moving
the knight and free the bishop but
that would leave this knight a type 2
undefended piece i would prefer to
fianchetto
i would prefer to find kiddo just out of
principle although there's nothing wrong
with moving the night out
but there's something about like the
f-file and the fact that this
knight is not particularly well
protected
um i would prefer to keep that knight
under guard of the other night if that
makes sense and notice how i'm trying to
find
a balance constantly between conceptual
reasoning and calculations i'm
calculating
but i'm not only calculating i'm also
using my intuition to make these micro
judgments like ah you know maybe i can
move my knight away but i don't really
want to
because that would leave this night kind
of loose and then maybe i'll look at the
game after
i finish it and see that knight c5 was
better that's possible
but um i'm playing the percentages here
i think that for every five moves that i
exercise this kind of reasoning in
uh you know three of them might be
better because i've decided to
you know err on the side of caution if
that makes sense yeah we can play bishop
a6 or bishop b7 either is good
and bishop a6 doesn't lead anywhere
because of a4
and we don't want to open that a file
for him
so let's go bishop b7 now we certainly
don't want to castle long why don't we
why don't we want to castle long in a
position like this
what specifically does that lead to
well at least well yeah knight a7 fork
remember night like this i mean you got
to pay attention that's that little guy
that little guy becomes a bit of a mofo
after castles long so
we're keeping the king in the center 8
300 so jesus
this is a ridiculous number
the king is less protected yes but i
kind of respectfully disagree
oh respect oh yeah yeah after castles it
is
so now we need to continue the process
of untangling our pieces
which is actually not that easy and
of course we cannot take on e4 for sure
because queen takes f7
um but let me think
i want to find something instructive we
can do
okay so we can do something pretty
interesting
yeah so the problem with the rook fade
is there's bishop takes h6
so i think the time has come guys for us
to play knight c5 yeah
the time has come for this move to be
played because
that bishop on b7 is actually very good
it's it's better than it would have been
on e6 because it is
pressuring the e4 pawn and um
i realized that i said earlier that this
would leave this knight
sort of unprotected but now i look at
this and i see that why there's no way
to explain why it's not going to sack a
queen on f6 that's absurd
um and i'll explain d5 after the game
it's the same reason why d5 was bad
earlier
oh castling long over the word is fine
all right so he drops his knife back
we immediately need to assess what the
threat is
don't just tunnel vision this pawn
because he's threatening bishop b5
and um we need to think of a way to stop
that
what comes to mind yeah white's actually
i mean my opponent is playing well
for sure so we can castle but we've sort
of determined that that
leads to even more problems after a5
so what shall we do
there's an interesting move here which i
think is not occurring to a lot of
people knight takes d3 is decent
but if i were to continue playing
devil's advocate guys
i would argue that knight takes d3 opens
up that c
file and that c file could be later used
by white to make counterplay
so let's try to defend against bishop b5
in the most like minimalist way possible
what is causing this to be a pin it's
the king placement on e8
so we just move the king to d8 this pawn
on d6
represents a very robust sort of
membrane against any rook that appears
on d1
that king is as safe as it gets on the
and it could later even move to see
it and there's moves like these that
cause a lot of people brief because they
seem
very flimsy but in reality they're
perfectly justified
so and if he goes b4 then the knight
loses its support then we can play
knight takes d3
yeah f8 you're stepping into this whole
thing and the knight d5 becomes
devastating
yeah only jams move their king that's
right okay
so
it's a waiting moment like it's very
hard for white to find ways to
increase the pressure yeah all
guys again remember there's always a
post game
phase where i answer specific questions
about like alternatives and stuff
and i do that because i want to maintain
the flow of the game during the game
yeah bishop a6 is interesting but i'll
explain why i didn't play it
okay so rook d1 and we talked about this
like this doesn't really create any
threats
we can take this pawn yeah actually we
can
why not takes takes takes takes and if
he takes f7 at the end we're gonna have
a little battery against this g2 square
yeah let's go it's we we've deployed all
of our pieces everything is in play
at some point you can go ahead and take
a small risk
well i can't castle him i move my king
yeah the donate link is not where the
donation command is not working
i think you can find it in my actual
stream maybe somebody could link
okay
so bishop b5 is not scary we bring our
queen back to c7
okay it does open the file for white but
remember that chess is a game of
tit-for-tat
ultimately you're gonna have to make
some concessions
i mean you are up a piece so ultimately
you will have to open up the position
i'll show you guys a really cool example
of somebody moving a king in the opening
in just a second
so it takes takes no problem and he can
take even here yeah so
here we have to be a little bit careful
our
our greatest asset is this guy
is this battery this battery makes his
queen
extremely tied down to the pawn or
he'll have to trade queens which is in
our favor anyway where should we go with
our king
we should escape it's important here to
play the right move the king e8 would
walk into queen takes f7
king d7 is one of two good moves i think
but then maybe queen h
but then yeah this is the best this is
very precise nicely done guys
and if he gives us this check then we
can step back to e8 and f7 is no longer
hanging
exactly what happens he's going to lose
on time but the position is
busted anyway okay this and here we just
need to check okay so if we take on f7
he'll probably give us a check we can
go basically anywhere there i mean we
can even go to to g7
we can go to g7 and if he gives us a
check on g3
we do not want to go to h7 and get
checkmated that's certainly not in our
plans but what can we do after king g7
queen g3
we can block either with the queen or
with the bishop and the game is over
we are up a rook and a piece yeah bishop
g5 and goodbye
great that was a very rich game thank
you uh good job i hope that
satisfied your curiosity
so night or defends bishop g5 knight bd7
now this this move is an interesting
history because it used to be
all of the rage then there was a while
where it was considered very bad due to
bishop c4
that used to bishop c4 used to be the
sort of quote-unquote refutation but
then
people found these ideas connected with
queen b6 and again this move got a
big resurgence now it's considered
basically along with e6 the main line
so f4 is one of the two main moves the
other is bishop c4 um
i have played knight bd7 over the board
only once
i believe let me just check and i played
it against ray robson
in the 2011 us championship i was in i
am ray was already at gm
i managed to i managed to win a a nice
game
although you know ray thrashed me plenty
of times
trust me i had one game with white and
one game with black
and with white i played mackenzie mulner
who is a
major night of expert and i lost and i
won with black so black won both games
where i reached this position let me see
yeah robson narrative 2011. interesting
okay so f4 is the main move now queen c7
queen f3 and h6 so in
my white game against mackenzie mulner i
i took on f6
and i tried something very interesting i
played like this so if white castles
long hair
black to play and win this is a very
common mistake at
all levels i mean i've had gm's fall
into this
good morning everybody who's joining
just now
uh heal hooks thank you for the tier one
yeah bishop g4
so my idea against mckenzie was was f5
yeah ray was stronger than the f5 to
shut down the bishop but this didn't
work very well
uh this actually was a very progress
game that i lost one of the
happiest i've ever felt after a loss i
mean i was like man i played well
but mckenzie played a brilliant game
holy smokes the real mr parish
25 ladies and gentlemen
thanks for such wonderful instructional
content good luck with a ton of
commentary
hopefully we'll get to see you playing
in tata still in the coming years thank
you sir
25 american dollars from the real mr
perry appreciate it
love to hear that and um do you
do you guys want to see like really
quickly just the beginning of that game
so there's going to be a lot to this
it's very complicated i'll just show you
guys
one of the ideas so f5 and mckenzie goes
queen c5 so basically what he says
is all right what is the drawback
specifically of the move f5 like
positionally
what is the drawback of this move what
does it weaken
what square in particular you guys
should just see this kind of thing yeah
i mean this square on e5
becomes very weak and maybe the knight
can get there maybe the queen he goes
queen c5
potentially eyeing that square for the
queen so i castle
and mackenzie goes g5 so
this is a simple move he he needs to
develop this bishop and
the secondary purpose of f5 is that i am
essentially discouraging from doing this
because i'm going to take that pawn and
you guys should be able to see that this
creates
a host of weaknesses around black's game
and the open f file is not in black's
favor
so he goes g5 and he tries to fianchetto
the bishop
and if i on bassant now then i think
actually bishop g4
might already be possible and and again
what black is going to win the exchange
so
that's not that's not something i wanted
to do
um and so i played a pretty crazy but
ftxg6 is actually the main line
i decided to go crazy and i played e5
and you guys will see the idea in just a
second sacrificing upon he takes it with
the pawn
and now knight d to b5 so my whole idea
was to open the d file so i wanted to
like checkmate him on c7 i was flirting
with this idea
and i also calculated that if a takes b5
then after bishop takes b5 check the
king is
essentially checkmated so black has to
do this i take it once
and now white to play and crush
this is a nice move but it's a simple
tactic you guys should see this now
queen b7 is inaccurate because of rook
d8 but
when you have that kind of idea you
should always consider what happens with
a reverse move or rook d7 first
is crushing king d7 queen b7 and you're
actually going to take this rook with
check because
after queen c7 you can give this check
and win the queen or deliver checkmate
so having calculated this line i went
knight db5
but uh mac goes e4 so he says
all right i'm going to use this pawn as
a decoy and get this knight out of the
picture
now there's nothing i can do about that
i have to take on e4
i absolutely have to have to take on e4
why don't i just transition to the
chess-based
scene guys one sec since this is a
really cool game
he plays a txb5 now it looks like he's
out of the woods but he's actually not
white to play and win white to play and
win
thank you else aj for the four months
white to play and when look at this pawn
on b5 we can take it with the bishop
it's going to be basically mate
so what we need to do is go rook to d5
skewering the queen to the pawn
the queen is the worst defender of a
piece you guys know that
queen must move boom goes the dynamite
and black has to give up
everything to avoid checking so once
again the knight is untouchable but
mckenzie just goes bishop g7 he just
develops
and um he's ready to castle if he
castles here remember he still can
then he's going to be completely out of
the woods and this bishop is going to be
a monster so i go rook d5 anyway
he drops his queen back f6 when i'm
continually trying to get his queen away
so that i can do what so that i can give
a check and now give a checkmate
unfortunately he doesn't budge he takes
to the bishop now rook d6
look at this move rook t6 he can't take
with the pawn that's illegal
yeah you can take with the queen but
then i take with the knight
but mckenzie's very calm queen c5 no
problem
rook takes f6 but now he eliminates this
cancer a takes b5
um and i go b4 and this is where
i'll show you guys one more move that he
played and then i'll stop
at this point i thought i was winning
this is what i calculated to
and the reason i thought that i was
winning is because
i didn't see a way the black's queen
could move and
uh protect b5 at the same time so i
thought okay he's gonna have to go here
and then i will take and then i'll chase
the king out and then
i will probably checkmate him like this
and uh there must be something here i
mean i i calculated these lines
so even if i don't do that the king is
just very weak but mackenzie in this
position made
a beautiful move beautiful move
queen c3 doesn't change the substance of
of things bishop takes me if i will
verify with a computer
if indeed rook f7 works
yes rook f7 is winning so the bottom
line here guys is that
the king has no spot to go if you go
king g8 then
then queen g6 and oh and beautiful mates
white has several win actually white is
only one mate
look at this white to play and made in
two amazing
it's not here it's not bishop c4 because
of he's a
rook f8 can't take with a queen pin
queen effect when he ate me
it's two rogue sacrifice um
but he didn't do any of that he found a
way and i'll give you guys a hint do not
move his queen
yeah rook a4 beautiful principia look at
you
rook a4 amazing move rook a4 just
pinning the pawn
and uh it turns out that this move shuts
down basically but white's
brunt of white's play um and
and the the bottom line is if if takes
takes the end game is clearly good for
black whites pawns are ruined et cetera
et cetera
well mack was uh very strong i am at
that point he's a gm now he's a night
off specialist
so i had to like play a3 i had to just
def he's attacking the pawn
this is such a funny move because it
looks like queen is saying but he's
actually attacking the b4 bomb so i have
to defend it
and now he completes his development and
and he pushes me around and he gets a
great position he finally castles
and and he you know the game lasted for
another 30 moves but
you can see now that his king is finally
safe and my king is the one that got
caught on the crossfire
so ultimately we got into a very
interesting end game
i mean this game was was just
fascinating and you know we both played
very well
but uh ultimately he just outplayed me
and uh
incredible tactical vision by mack
so that's just chess you know you can
play a brilliant game and you can lose
that's just
what it is so anyways that's why we play
the night off with both sides you get
this kind of fun games
um my memory is good uh for like
capitals and stuff i don't remember
everything i don't have a photographic
memory
but i do remember like random stuff okay
so queen f3h6 bishop h4 so that's bishop
takes f6 he goes here now we sacrifice
the pawn
now we sacrifice the pawn so a lot of
people here were like and he goes bishop
g3 which is a big mistake
what happens if he takes upon
um let me just verify with current
theory
yeah so g5 takes takes takes now this
position had occurred in
uh over 298 games at this point and the
move is queen c5
yeah queen c5 so you basically you fork
the knight in the bishop with your queen
i am yes i'm not in hotel am i in my
apartment
i am at home queen c5 and black
sorry white must defend both pieces at
the same time he has bishop b3 right
but now we go 95 and we attack the queen
the queen must move so queen e2
is the most popular
but now this looks like it benefits why
did we put the queen deliberately
on a pin square but it turns out this
bishop on e3 is very vulnerable
this bishop on e3 is very vulnerable to
what moves specifically
yeah black is dominating initiative wise
black is calling the shots here and now
the move knight e5 to g4
bingo and that bishop is
very valuable uh you can't just give
that bishop up you can't just
castle um because of take stakes and
bishop h6 wins the queen
why not knight fg4 that's a good
question
what did you guys see oh queen
retreating yeah so i just said knight
knight g4
um and the move is not eg4 which might
seem weird like why are we repositioning
that night and
you guys will see the reason in just a
second
you guys will see the reason in a second
and the reason is very specific
um after knight eg4 bishop g1
how can black prevent white from
castling queensland
while developing a piece
bishop h6 good there's your page six
stopping
the castle and white is no like very
effective discovery
now the reason we don't go night eg oh
sorry seriously
the reason we don't do this the reason
we do this
and not this using the method of
comparison we can ask ourselves a key
question
what squares does white have access to
in this position
which he doesn't have access to in the
position with the unite
and you guys should be able to see that
it's this nasty square on d5
boom and b4 is now a huge threat because
uh that queen is going to have a very
hard time keeping c7 under control
so this is one of those things where you
want to bash your head against the wall
from a logical perspective you would
want to leave this knight on the outpost
but
there's this very specific consideration
that this knight has to defend d5
that's just chess you know i'm sorry but
these openings
that's why memorization is important in
the night or because like these
things are hard to come up with on
demand
and uh if knight f5 which is a mistake
but it's been played
10 times black is already winning but
23 70 went into this for example white
black to play
what does black do just don't make
mistakes exactly
black to play queen b4 is good yeah
queen before attacking the pawn counter
attacking v2
and uh white white's position simply
collapses because he cannot castle
so if if knight takes h6 then after
queen takes b2 white can resign because
black's gonna take
frickin everything and uh
this was um you guys want to know
something funny
in 2012 this position
occurred on the board in a blitz game
and black was alexander donchenko rated
2294 at that time
who is currently a participant in
wakansai which i will be commentating in
less than two hours
it goes full circle this guy knew about
this
you know nine years ago
um and and and the game is just over how
to win
okay so everybody i think you can see
that that this is winning
uh because we're just gonna win a piece
so in this position
um in this position let me see
was the other okay queen c4 was the
other move people played
but but now you just take here and take
your friend anyway this is over
this is horrible if i can say
i could try to pronounce the torture
accent
i can try my best okay
so that is the label and now white
obviously shouldn't play like this
um the move knight f5 is a mistake after
after bishop h6
uh but you know this gets very complex
now the last thing i'll mention if in
this position white takes on f6
then black gets a lot of positional
counter play positional compensation
because
um because oh rook b1 there
so if rook b1 the knight takes e4 that's
another interesting detail
so this position bishop e3 here here
here
uh sorry bishop g1 h6
yeah if you go queen rook b1 then i can
sorry
if you go rook b1 then knight takes c4
cutting the legs off of this knight
queen takes c4 queen takes e4 and this
end game is horrible for white i mean
one black's gonna win seats soon
okay so this is just crushing
um and in this position people were also
asking about bishop takes sepsis but
when you give up the dark squared bishop
here
and you give up the dark squared bishop
you
um you give up sort of bishop h6 will be
uncontested and like the king
will never be able to castle so this is
just bad for for white
in general so that's uh one of the the
lines in the night earth that's why
bishop h4 has fallen out of fashion
bishop takes f6 is actually still the
main line this in f5
okay and obviously queen f3 is also not
for so you can play queen e2 here you
can play queen d2
queen d3 there's a bunch of moves here
so
after you know bishop g3 happened
cayenne i mean this game is basically
already over g takes f4 and
i would probably dial it back and go
bishop f2 but even now after e5
uh black gets this beautiful pawn chain
and blacks apple pawn this is just bad
so bishop f4 e5
and uh and and this is just over so
they're really only a couple of things
here
uh one is queen takes c2 is very
tempting but after rook c1
the queen must must move allowing knight
c7
the second thing is um this this idea of
of just developing and not you know
bogging ourselves down a lot of people
were asked why not go
d5 and there is a specific reason in
this position white is a tactic can
somebody find it for me
somebody find it for me
yeah so it takes d5 right queen to el
carissa
fresh reinforcement queen d5 and ic7
typical idea
so we don't want to be too cavalier
about opening up the center so that's
why we finished our development first
and only only then after moving our king
away from the pin simply moving it
did we take on e4 and if white take on
f7 then we can just go like knight g5
opening up the attack on the g2 pawn and
after queen f2
black has a very pretty win who can spot
it and then he'll end the speed run with
that
yeah it's simple we want this pawn gone
so queen h1 will be made and knight h3
is a good way of doing that fork
thinking of the queen good
so he played here but i mean now we
easily navigate through the checks
and we aren't afraid to enter this
principle line because we see that we
have bishop g5
[Music]
you